- C'est à la main et en équipe,
s'organisent à Krementchouk.
C'est une scène de fin du monde.
Les pompiers, aidés par des
civils, complètement dépassés
par l'ampleuunununununununununue
des airs, sans aucun préavis.)))
À l'intérieur, on peut entendre
les les les secouristes chercher
des survivants, aveuglés par
la pouss
On ignore combien sont morts,
engloutis par les flammes.
Car il était à peine 16 h
et le centre commercial était
achalandé, selon les autorités,
quand deux explosiononont été
entendues et ressenties.
"C'était si puissant que j'ai
été jetée au sol avec mon petit
dans les bras", dit cessssssssss
un à un et avec beaucoup de
difficultés.
"C'est complètement surréel,
dit cet homme, sous le choc.
du centre commercial."
Il faut dégsasasasasasasasasass
femmes et les enfants qui sont
coincés 'i'i'intérieur", dit
Anton Herashchenko. Il est un
des conseillers du ministre des
Affaires intérieures, qui est
venu constater de ses propres
yeux ce que le président
Volodymyr Zelensky qualifie
La ville industrielle de
Krementchuk, dans le centre
du pays, a
jusqu'ici épargnée. Outre cette
usine d'entretien de véhicules
juste à côté du centre
commercial, elle n'avait aucune
valeur stratégique, a déclaré
le préntntnt depuis Kiev, la
capitale. Il venait d'ailleurs
tout juste de plaider sa cause
et d
lui fournisse des systèmes de
déququququququququququququququq.
Selon la défense ukrainienne,
deux missiles à longue soe soe n
cause. Sur ces images, que nous
n'avons pas puhehehentifier, on
peut voir le premier, quelques
secondes avant l'impact.
"Une horreur absolue, un geste
dededededededededededededededede
photo de l'attaque, en ajoutantr
la vérité."
L'ONU a aussi dénoncé
tatataque.
Mais la Russie rejeaiaiaiaiaiar
la plupart des bombardements qui
semblent viser lesililils depuis
le début de la guerre. Ce soir,
à Krementchouk, des sirènese e e
alors qu'on cherche encore dans
la ferra e e et les décombres,
et le bilan continue de
s'alourdir